[Applauso]
cosa pensate
quando vedete questo
che storia l'amore esiste anch'io vorrei
una storia così che fortunati mio marito
non è così e cosa pensate se vi
dicessimo che però non siamo così tutti
i giorni ma che per arrivare qui bisogna
costruire una relazione felice
se avete mai pensato siamo cresciuti con
il vissero felici e contenti
nei film si conoscono vivono mille
avventure una crisi che prontamente
risolvono nel loro a mezza di film si
baciano
poi si sposano e vissero felici e
contenti bene i cartoni che guardano i
nostri figli
stessa cosa io da bambina invece mi
chiedevo e dopo questi davvero non
litigano mai più davvero i problemi che
c'erano fino a 5 minuti fa non vengono
mai più a bussare alla porta
ecco adesso invece che sono grande ho
capito che in realtà la sfida è
l'avventura inizia dopo che il drago che
sembra di aver appena sconfitto in
realtà non è nulla a confronto un
matrimonio o una relazione longeva
ma come facciamo costruire questa
relazione felice
prima di tutto dobbiamo smantellare
l'idea di felicità che abbiamo non siamo
felici davvero tutti i giorni e non
tutto quello che facciamo in una
giornata ci rende felici non ci facciamo
sempre con la stessa passione del primo
limone dell'ultima figlia del cinema e
non guardiamo sempre con voi volentieri
l'ennesima serie tv romantica dove già
capito tutta la trama nei primi dieci
minuti e non siamo neanche qui per dirvi
che la felicità si trova nelle piccole
cose quindi ma cosa gli diciamo allora
secondo me dobbiamo dire che la felicità
è molto più complessa di quello che ci
vogliono far credere che un po secondo
noi come andare sull'altalena
ogni tanto se su ogni tanto gesù ma è
complesso davvero divertente se dovessi
chiedervi quali sono gli elementi per
una relazione felice probabilmente tanti
di poi mi devo dire io li leggo perché
così che vi sono rispetto sostegno
sicurezza stima intimità sesso buona
comunicazione e sentire di essere
valutati
adesso sappiamo gli avevamo scritti
anche lì quanti noi facciamo giusti
alcuni stesse ancora alcuni sì però se
dovessimo chiedervi invece cosa non
dovrebbe esserci in una relazione
ecco magari alcuni direbbero litigare
troppo spesso criticare essere criticati
non andare dall'altro non chiedere
supporto
ostilità violenza ora andrà in tutto ne
sa quanti ne facciamo sbagliati forse
forse fin troppo
quindi ora quello che accada noi e
secondo me quello che accade anche voi
ogni tanto e che non ha coppia nei
momenti di crisi perché arrivano prima o
poi arrivano sempre capita di vedere o
tutto bianco o tutto nero e ci
dimentichiamo che probabilmente una
relazione vera è un mix tra queste due
cose e se una relazione felice
a tutti questi elementi è una relazione
malsana e tossica a tutti quelli una
relazione vera come la nostra per
esempio probabilmente su un'altalena tra
le due ora voi direte ma perché ci
raccontate tutto questo perché vogliamo
mettere i fatti nostri su questo
bellissimo palco quello facendo su visto
però pensa ancora qui
in realtà pensiamo che in ogni relazione
ci sia uno o più momenti in cui almeno
uno dei due dice basta che magari ogni
tanto ci sta ogni tanto ha ragione ma
guardando la nostra storia sono grato di
aver imparato a fare la differenziata e
di aver imparato cosa c'è di mio
cosa c'è di tu o cosa c'è di nostro da
ripulire riciclare ogni tanto da buttare
veramente ma ora come si fa la
differenziata
prima di tutto la bisogna voler fare
perché parliamoci chiaro ogni tanto è
molto più facile prendere e buttare
tutto nello stesso filone co2
e se non la si vuole fare e inutile
continuare a dire al partner butta la
carta della carta
però
in una terapia di coppia la prima cosa
che chiede terapeuta è se è disposto a
fare un passo verso l'altro se la
risposta è no la differenza tra la farai
mai ma se le risposte si
solitamente si dice ci vediamo il
prossimo appuntamento in realtà si può
iniziare a costruire qualcosa in questo
momento però spesso scatta un'altra
domanda
perché adesso prima non era così cos'è
cambiato tutto fosse cambiato mica se lo
stesso ha sposato e certo che sono
cambiato tumi conosciuto 21 anni ero
studente e non avevo ancora mal di
schiena
cioè tu non sei cambiata la fine io
forse ero un pò li sull'ospedale che
voleva un salvatore adesso ti sembra una
che bisogna essere salvata a meno ma
davvero siamo cambiati così tanto ma ci
siamo dimenticati di cosa ci ha spinto a
farci innamorare
sempre dal terapeuta quando eravamo fa
il divano a cercare i punti fermi della
nostra relazione
ci ha chiesto cosa ci piace nell'altro
che se ci pensate è una domanda davvero
banale se paghi un terapeuta 120 euro
l'ora ti incazzi pure però in questa
banalità noi abbiamo trovato in realtà
una risposta davvero essenziale per una
relazione felice o perlomeno da dove
partire per fare la differenziata
quindi andrea le catechiste non malata
di mente sicuramente che sei molto
frizzante la tua energia la tua passione
la tua curiosità
questo questo pathos beh io della tua
semplicità che sei molto più razionale
di man e che si pratica un vero però
scusa cos'è che non sopporti di me
adesso sei un po troppo razionale troppo
semplice e soprattutto questa camicia
dieci anni cioè addosso corbello però si
e tu allora cioè noi siamo in continuo
movimento stiamo facendo il giro del
mondo a 10 mesi possiamo fermarci un
attimino a caso fermi quindi quello che
il terapeuta fa ma non vi dice e noi
abbiamo capito quel tempo e che in
quella domanda li vuole riportare ai
perché vi siete innamorati e che quelle
stesse cose molto spesso sono le stesse
cose che mi fanno perdere la testa in
altro modo dieci anni dopo ovvero quindi
c'è qualcosa che non funziona dov'è
l'inghippo che secondo noi confondiamo
il cambiamento esterno con quello
interno confondiamo il cambiamento del
mondo con quello della persona quando
diciamo il mio partner non mi dà più le
stesse attenzioni di prima sei uno
sbadato se sempre in ritardo hai sempre
la stessa camicia e trasandata non te la
cambi mai in realtà ci dimentichiamo che
quei comportamenti sono l'espressione di
quella parte lì che tanto amiamo e di
cui ci siamo innamorati all'inizio ok
traduciamo questo concetto
odio le camicie che non ti cambi mano il
fatto che non seguì la moda e non se non
sta in d'azione io vorrei fermarmi ogni
tanto è vero però amo il fatto che tu
sei sempre curiosa city sempre piena di
energia e spesso treni tutti e due il
problema quindi non è il cambiamento il
problema sono le basi ogni tanto ci
dimentichiamo della persona che abbiamo
di fianco e ci dimentichiamo della sua
storia ed è perché dei suoi
comportamenti ci dimentichiamo del
valore dietro quella camicia
stropicciata quindi adesso secondo me ci
serve un nuovo bidone vogliamo mettere
sì quale quello del renamo ramento
ok e cosa ci metti dentro ci mettiamo
dentro tutte quelle emozioni quei
sentimenti quei valori dell'altra
persona che ogni tanto con il tempo
tendiamo a dimenticare che chi
sbiadiscono perdono un po di vividezza
ed è importante metterlo in quel bidone
lì perché dobbiamo creare dei ponti
ponti tra quelli che eravamo quindi che
siamo e quelli che stiamo per diventare
ponti che servono a contestualizzare i
periodi di vita e le nuove esigenze
ponti che ti fanno dire amore suoi per
la cena di domani quelle importanti mi
compro una camicia nuova e me la metto
pure va bene allora sai cosa faccio io
ci fermavamo fare un effettivo
e questa cosa non vuol dire lì non c'era
noi stessi ma vuol dire creare un'unione
ed è importante ma perché serve questo
passo perché una volta introdotto il
nuovo bidone del re innamoramento si può
iniziare a costruire perché così le cose
sanno dove mettersi trovano un posto
siamo presi proprio te lo ricordi cosa
abbiamo fatto noi no il gioco dell'oca è
vero quando me l'hanno proposto ammetto
che anch'io era un pochettino sbigottito
abbiamo preso un foglio di carta e
l'abbiamo diviso in tappe come le case
dell'ater il gioco dell'oca dove vi ha
messo tutte le nostre tappe fondamentali
della nostra storia abbia cercato di
definire quelle che ci hanno fatto stare
molto bene e quelle che invece ci hanno
fatto stare molto male è perché questo
perché ogni tanto importante avere una
visione di insieme e mettere ordine
fatto questo gioco bisogna chiedersi
scusa si dimentica sempre questo pezzo
quando si capisce
quello che non han dato si capisce anche
quanto male sei fatto ma la cosa più
bella che ci ha insegnato questo gioco e
che nei momenti belli molto spesso sono
condivisi invece momenti brutti sono
diversi per ognuno e questo ci fa
sentire nel primo caso
felici se invece nel secondo caso soli e
abbandonati
ed è qui che dobbiamo ricucire a
ripartire da quando ci siamo sentiti
soli abbandonati e tirare fuori la roba
dal bidone perché molto probabilmente in
quel periodo lì abbiamo sbagliato fa la
differenziata e abbiamo messo la
plastica nella carta quindi ora facciamo
il punto
abbiamo parlato del passato con il gioco
dell'oca abbiamo parlato nel presente
abbiamo capito perché ancora questa
camicia stropicciata realtà quanto pare
la virtù è però adesso dobbiamo capire
il futuro perché ammettiamolo non esiste
alcun motivo razionale che in questo
momento ci farebbe dire voglio passare
tutta la vita con una persona
soprattutto adesso che abbiamo appena
fatto la lista di tutto quello che non
hanno e tutti i punti e tutti i suoi
difetti
però il bello quando iniziò un percorso
del genere e che a un certo punto
avviene la magia è in realtà scopre di
aver messo le basi per una relazione
felice perché in realtà per qualche
motivo dopo essersi ascoltati davvero
torna la scintilla che molti
taglierebbero corto e direbbero amore
però noi siamo qui per fare un discorso
sull'amore senza usare la parola amore
per ben tre volte vabbè però quindi per
il futuro cosa si fa adesso è poi facile
perché abbiamo messo sul tavolo quindi
non ci resta che mettere delle nuove
regole possono essere diverse per ognuno
noi abbiamo fatto dei posti troviamo
messe sul comodino dei post it su i
nostri miglioramenti da fare a tipo i
buoni propositi di capodanno o quelli
settembre dato che siamo in tema su
legge scritto essere più romantico dare
più attenzione a giulia che qua visto
specificato a giulia ascoltare davvero
mia c'è scritto non alzare la voce
arrabbiarmi meno lavorare meno
sembra una cavolata ma vi giuro che
lasciare quei posti teli sul comodino fa
in modo che ogni tanto lo sguardo cade e
ti ricordi di quella coppia che ha
promesso di dare il meglio di sé ma la
regola più importante che ci siamo messi
che non abbiamo scritto sul post it e
che una volta aperti quei bidoni e aver
tirato fuori tutto questo aver scoperto
tutte quelle cose qui vissuti quelle
esperienze quei bisogni dell'altro ma
anche di noi stessi preso questo
dobbiamo mettere al primo posto e non
dobbiamo dimenticarlo mai custodirlo per
sempre come un po la storia con nostri
capo la perla la sabbia potrebbe
uccidere l'ostrica ma l'ostrica ne fa
una perla in una reazione uguale a volte
l'immondizia puzza che a volte si
sbaglia fa la differenziata
insomma rischi far male un po tutti ma
tirata fuori e riprendendo e mettendo le
cose il proprio posto scopri che da una
bottiglia di plastica può nascere un
file che ti tiene caldo e che abbraccia
vi aspettavate un discorso wow con la
chiusura col botto scommetto non ce
l'abbiamo perché secondo noi non c'è la
ricetta perfetta per una relazione
felice o perlomeno noi non ce l'abbiamo
però in questi 11 anni insieme qualcosa
di mai imparato abbiamo imparato che
l'amore non basta
ma la faccia di tutti quei film che
abbiamo visto e di cui siamo cresciuti e
che l'amore va ricordato il non
dimenticato non è un ingrediente che
puoi mettere una sola volta e poi non
aggiungerlo più che non è una torta
preparata uguale per tutti quegli
istruzioni sul retro che alle volte
serve più zucchero e altre volte più
farina che di norma va continuato a
mescolare per amalgamare bene gli
ingredienti e alle volte qualcosa va
storto e anche se la ricetta è perfetta
ogni tanto magari i tempi di cottura
sono sbagliati e quindi magari abbiamo
bisogno di tempi diversi
abbiamo capito scrisse manconi
ingrediente non è così facile trovare un
sostituto sul banco del supermercato
abbiamo capito soprattutto che questa
storia in questa ricetta la si fa in due
e che ognuno porta gli ingredienti
necessari e che nonostante la ricetta
vada migliorata di anno in anno quando
viene buona
e l'amore ridotto di volo però l'amore
non è razionale
buon appetito
[Applauso]